[Musique]
bonjour tout le monde pour celles et
ceux qui ne me connaissent pas vous le
savez maintenant je m'appelle carmela
mauricie par mauricie donc je m'appelle
carmela j'ai 40 ans aujourd'hui 40 ans
le 4 du 4,79
sur cette photo là j'ai un an et si à
l'époque on m'avait dit que d'une part
je n'aimerais plus les gâteaux mais
alors là plus du tout et que d'autre
part je serai là ce soir devant vous
littéralement mort de trouille à l'idée
d'inaugurer ce premier ted
moi je me serais arrêté de grandir tout
de suite je serais resté bloqué dans les
années 79
je m'appelle donc carmela chez 40 ans et
je suis l'heureuse maman de lutter qui
lui à 8 ans je vous la corde jusqu'ici
c'est assez banal
on entend bien la petite musique sucrée
habituel qui accompagnent ces gens qu'on
appelle parents des êtres certes
fatigués cerner mais relativement
heureux de leur vie et des progrès de
leur progéniture
il n'y a pas vraiment de recette il n'y
a pas vraiment de décalage je m'appelle
carmela aujourd'hui j'ai 40 ans et je
suis l'heureuse maman de lutter huit ans
porteur d'une trisomie 21 et d'autisme
est là la petite musique sucrée s'arrête
le disque saute ça fait comme un larsen
dans vos têtes
vous êtes probablement en train de vous
demander comment je fais pour être
l'heureuse maman d'un enfant de ces deux
déficience faut savoir que luther est
entré dans ma vie comme une tempête
littéralement 15 janvier 2010 au volley
l'hôpital est bloquée par une tempête de
neige
l'équipe de nuit n'arrive pas à partir
l'équipe de jour n'arrive pas à venir
et c'est précisément ce moment que
luther choisi pour faire son entrée sur
scène son papa et moi on découvre sa
trisomie 21 le lendemain de sa naissance
et son autisme bien plus tard donc non
on n'était pas au courant pendant la
grossesse
et oui c'était la surprise à la
maternité
je vous passe les détails dans monde qui
s'ouvre en deux pour vous aspirer vers
un enfer de colère de tristesse et
d'incompréhension pourquoi lui
pourquoi moi qu'est-ce qu'on avait bien
pu faire s'en sont suivis vous vous en
doutez des torrents de larmes
j'ai pleuré où il vraiment beaucoup
pleuré j'ai fait enlever le prénom de
l'apport de la maternité j'ai remballer
le champagne que ma mère m'avait offert
gérant ballet l'abc la généticienne j'ai
interdit à toute personne de venir nous
rendre visite et j'ai pleuré pleuré
pleuré
jusqu'à ce que je me rende compte que
les larmes n'étaient pas une énergie
renouvelable
c'était pas une énergie du tout cette
photo que vous voyez derrière moi je la
déteste
elle me fait mal lutter à quelques
semaines peut-être en modeuse je me
rappelle plus
il a déjà les yeux grands ouverts vers
le monde qu'il a envie de découvrir
d'explorer et moi je cache mes yeux
bouffis par les larmes et la tristesse
derrière un rideau de cheveux je la
déteste mais en même temps je veux la
garder je veux pas l'effacer parce que
c'est la seule et unique photo où je
suis triste à côté de lutter il paraît
que dans la vie y'a pas de hasard qu'il
n'y a que des rendez vous et bien c'est
un sacré rendez-vous qu'on m'avait filé
ce 15 décembre mais ça j'allais me
rendre compte bien plus tard décembre
2010 donc devant nous en corps médical
qui nous dépeint un tableau noir charbon
mon fils est une aberration
chromosomique ces charmants aberrations
chromosomiques dès sa naissance un
enfant porteur de trisomie 21 présente
les signes suivants un profil aplati des
yeux [ __ ] 1 et piquante une troisième
paupières verticale un pont nasale plat
une hypertrophie et une profusion de la
langue une petite tête de petites
oreilles les petits sont ronds et ses
membres sont petits ils possèdent un pli
unique dans les paumes de la main appelé
plis palmer transverses unique
il présente unie poteau ni musculaire et
une hyper laxité importante
toute sa vie il subira de graves retards
temps dans le développement psychomoteur
et intellectuel que dans le langage
en gros on était en train de m'annoncer
que ma vie était fichu que je pouvais
m'arrêter de travailler immédiatement
que mon fils resteraient coller à mes
basques malade toute sa vie et bien
aujourd'hui je suis persuadé que la
virulence de la douleur que j'ai
ressentie ce jour là elle est liée
évidemment à la brutalité de l'annoncé
comme je vous le disais on n'était pas
au courant elle est liée à la violence
du vocabulaire utilisé qui a estimé un
jour que c'était une bonne idée de
parler à 2 à des parents de
d'aberrations chromosomiques
mais elle est aussi est intimement lié à
l'image qu'on me renvoyaient de mon fils
a un jour on me disait que mon fils
marcherait plus tard qu'il ne parlerait
peut-être pas qu'il ne lirait
probablement pas qu'il ne mangerait pas
seul qu'il serait petit gros qu'il
aurait le cheveux plats et fils à ce
qu'ils seraient souvent malade et qu'il
mourrait probablement avant moi il avait
un jour et je comprenais pas je
comprenais pas comment ce tout petit
bout de chromosomes en plus parvenait
être à ce point omnipotent comment ce
petit bouddha dn parvenait à l'impact et
de la pointe des pieds jusqu'à la pointe
de ses cheveux en passant par sa peau
ses organes et son intelligence
j'ai vraiment pas compris je dois vous
dire qu'au début de la vie de lutter je
le place est sur une courbe de
développement
vous savez seront de courtes qu'on
trouve sur internet à un jour un enfant
fait ceci ya trois mois un enfant fait
cela est passionnant je le mettais sur
cette courbe avec un écart vous vous en
doutez qui sont agrandies c'est de
semaine en semaine jusqu'au jour où je
me suis rendu compte que mon fils
n'était pas ordinaire
il ne serait jamais sur cette courbe il
avait une courbe et une temporalité qui
lui était propre et finalement ce petit
bout de chromosomes omnipotent ça a été
la clé qui m'a permis à moi d'entamer
mon voyage en mongolie intérieure
une destination qui n'a d'effrayant que
la méconnaissance absolue qu'on en a je
suis une grande insomniaque et donc j'ai
passé toutes les premières nuits de la
vie de lutter à me documenter parce que
je sais pas vous mais moi je ne
connaissais rien de la trisomie 21
et donc j'ai lu beaucoup sur ce que
c'est exactement comment ce chromosome y
fait pour agir sur autant de deux
dimensions de la vie humaine la trisomie
ce que c'est la trisomie ce qu'on peut
faire et surtout ce qu'on fait ailleurs
parce que c'est là que je me suis rendu
compte que plus que moi c'était le monde
médical qui était en complet décalage
ils étaient coincés dans une vision
complètement passéiste des personnes en
situation de handicap est porteur de
trisomie 21 est pire que ça il était
bloqué dans un déterminisme génétique
absolue alors évidemment nos gènes nous
détermine les jeunes ont une incidence
sur ce que nous sommes évidemment le 47e
chromosomes de lutter un impact
importantissime sur sa vie mais il ya
les 46 autres les 46 qu'il partage avec
vous et moi et au delà de ce paquet
d'adr ya tout le reste il y à l'amour
qu'on peut lui porter il y à l'éducation
qu'on lui donne il ya les efforts que la
société fait ou pas pour lui laisser une
place il ya surtout la force avec
laquelle moi je me bats pour qu'il ait
une place étrangement en maternité on ne
m'a pas parlé d'inclusion étrangement
maternité on ne va pas parler
d'intégration étrangement maternité on
ne m'a pas parlé de toutes ces personnes
porteuses d'une trisomie 21 qui une fois
adulte était mannequin peintre boulanger
pizzaïolo lancer leur propre marque de
vêtements voire de chaussettes
on en a pas parlé depuis lutter de son
côté la participer à des castings il a
fait de la figuration dans une série
pour france 2 il a été mannequin pour
une ligne de vêtement et pourant
calendrier il a défilé avec des lauréats
de concours de beauté
il apprend à lire à écrire il communique
à travers trois langages
il joue du piano de la guitare du djembé
du synthé il se réveille tous les matins
à 6 heures avec le sourire et surtout
lutter il a apporté de la joie dans ma
vie lutter in a mis au défi permanent
d'augmenter mes compétences de devenir
quelqu'un de meilleur de me surpasser et
je me dis que c'est finalement peut-être
pour ça que la société des gens
ordinaires n'aime pas l'inclusion n'aime
pas les personnes en situation
d'handicap
parce qu'une société inclusive c'est une
société qui nous demande à nous les
capable de faire un effort de nous
mettre en défi pour laisser une place
aux personnes en situation d'handicap
je vais vous raconter une anecdote qui
s'est passé bien avant la naissance de
lutter j'avais l'habitude de passer mes
vacances en italie d'aller régulièrement
dans le même magasin de souliers ou
travailler une vendeuse porteuses de
trisomie 21
avec mes réflexes belge j'ai dit aux
gérants je le trouvais fort charitable
d'engager une personne handicapée
il m'a répondu que c'était pas du tout
de la charité que c'était sa meilleure
vendeuse elle ne savait certes pas
compté mais elle avait un rapport
clients imparable et c'est vrai que la
plupart du temps je voulais acheter une
paire je ressortais avec trois vols
étaient vraiment très forte
au moment de passer à la caisse elle
appuyée sur une sonnette une de ses
collègues arrivent et encaissés comment
ça se fait qu'il ya quelques années en
italie une personne porteuse de trisomie
21 peut travailler dans un magasin de
chaussures et pas en belgique 1979 il ya
40 ans donc l'italie arrête
l'enseignement spécialisé ferme les
écoles prend le capital humain et les
enfants à l'aimer dans les écoles
ordinaires et donc ce monsieur il avait
grandi non pas avec cette vendeuse mais
avec d'autres enfants en situation de
handicap
il y avait appris que derrière le terme
il y avait certes des déficiences plus
ou moins importante mais il y avait
aussi des potentiels beaucoup de
potentiel alors ce soir si j'ai osé
monter sur scène et dépasser ma peur
c'est pour vous demander à vous aussi
d'oser osé parler non pas de personnes
handicapées mais deux personnes en
situation de handicap
dawes et imaginer les compétences
derrière les déficiences si ce soir j'ai
osé monter sur scène c'est parce que je
suis intimement convaincu que nous avons
toutes et tous à y gagner en nous
enrichissant des singularités de chacun
et enfin si ce soir j'ai osé monter sur
scène c'est parce que ça fait huit ans
que mon fils lui terme prouve que loin
d'être ordinaire
la vie peut être trois fois plus mûr
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous